but let's advance from this topic so i
don't just beat a dead horse because we
do have this story from the south china
morning post
civil war and dirty bombs fbi and us
department of homeland security on alert
for threats after raid on trump home u.s
law enforcement agencies prepare for
potentially violent fallout from fbi
raid on donald trump's mar-a-lago home
fbi and dhs identify multiple
articulated threats and calls for the
targeted killing of judicial law
enforcement and government officials
yo there's a
there's another story from axios that
goes along with it that um
i don't even know if i can start getting
into because the language used by this
guy is so egregious
pennsylvania man arrested for
threatening slaughter fbi this is what
it's
i don't know you guys ready to drink
civil war oh my so i said it the first
time in the title of the south china
morning post article but
i'll tell you this while the fbi is
claiming there are these very real
threats
and that there's there's cons they're
concerned about them
jane's revenge has admitted to engaging
in terrorism they've taken credit for
this and where's the fbi i'll tell you
where it is no it's just marjorie taylor
green trying to get them declared a uh
domestic terrorist organization i mean
the fbi is not just it's literally her i
mean i'm sure she has support in
congress but like no one is taking
action against james revenge remember
when
like when you're reading the headline
they're like they're threatening uh
government officials do you remember
when that guy showed up at brett
kavanaugh's house i mean
they're acting like
you know violence is one-sided which it
really is not in this country and
obviously i think most threats come from
extremists that don't represent the
majority of people on either side of the
spectrum but
this is
this is very bizarre but we forget that
it's double-sided i i think it's
actually simple if you're the fbi and
you're raiding donald trump
the right is very mad at you if you're
the fbi and you're investigating trump
for russiagate the right is very mad at
you and so imagine you're sitting in
your chair
and you're uh you know reading the news
and all of a sudden antifa is just
screaming they hate you you're evil
you're corrupt and then people on the
right are not really saying a whole lot
you'd be like man these guys are crazy
over here they won't stop talking about
how they want to do evil stuff
this is what the fbi is basically doing
for one they're i mean this is an
example of their overt political bias
they engage in weaponized politicking
going after trump for russiagate clearly
fake the fbi uh kevin kleinsmith i
believe his name was
altered an email fabricating evidence to
justify spying on the trump campaign
then trump supporters get mad at the fbi
say you're all corrupt then a bunch of
other fbi agents who are not involved
and don't know that this corruption is
occurring just think the trump
supporters are crazy because hey i
didn't do anything wrong
then the fbi starts pointing at the
people who are pointing at them and
they're completely ignoring antifa in
the far left and
cherry on top they're getting all their
news from the corporate press who's been
actively defending you know antifa and
the left to a great degree not all the
time but to a great degree so
it's not so much i would say that you
need to be concerned about a conspiracy
but an emergent phenomenon where these
are the things that are causing the fbi
to be inflamed like to target trump
supporters and the right
well they've drummed out over the years
they've gotten rid of the people in the
fbi that were
there
that we're not
willing to do this kind of thing to
demonize
people that support trump this is part
of just demonizing anybody that
disagrees with the powers that be
that's what they've been doing since
january 6th it's what they they that's
why they've been terrorizing american
citizens who just went to washington on
january 6 and weighed flags and that's
why when you have an actual person who
is camped outside of brett kavanaugh's
house and is going to kill him that
mentioned for a couple of days but then
they make these sweeping pronouncements
right about all these threats it's the
same thing as when they declared all the
parents that went to school board
meetings as potential domestic
terrorists everything everybody that
disagrees with the
uh weaponized fbi with with you know the
government's
the fbi has become our stasi now they
are just investigating people who they
consider to be enemies of the
administration enemies of the government
people who disagree
why aren't they going
why do you think they're just not going
after
jane's revenge or the left i mean maybe
they are they just don't care i
they absolutely don't care they they
agree with jane's revenge they're not
going to investigate them just like they
you know the blm and nt for riots in
2020 and 2021 they didn't do they didn't
treat those people the way they're
treating the january six people so we
we've talked about something a bit in
the past couple of weeks that um
if joe biden were to pardon all of the
january 6 people that his popularity
would spike democrats would start
cheering and clapping about how gracious
they are and trump supporters wouldn't
have much to say other than well that
was the right thing to do thank you for
doing it
do you think that sorry they can't do
that the biden would never ever do that
and i don't think his democrat base
would cheer that they would be furious i
disagree
they they
they don't care for
lot moral logic they care for winning
and if joe biden does something they'll
say we are good people while donald
trump was chanting lock em up we are
doing the right thing and and reaching
an olive branch because we are honorable
that's of course what they would do i
don't think so i don't think you
understand how deeply they hate people
like me i think i i do but i think
they they care more about
they wouldn't want to claim to claim
defeat if if joe biden came out and said
look
tensions have gotten way beyond our
control in this country we need a sign
of good faith
you know and then he says something like
what these men these people on january 6
did was wrong however
the continued prosecution is only
ripping this country apart and we need
to find a path towards you know clemency
and you know commutation for these
individuals so that we can learn to heal
as a nation i think the left would
absolutely have no choice the democrats
but to agree with biden otherwise they'd
be claiming defeat and they're not going
to do that they're not going to admit
they're wrong they're going to say see
we were the good guys the whole time
it's trump who's bad and we're honorable
and then trump supporters could only say
well that was the right thing to do
thank you joe biden some might be alike
it's political it's a political move but
it would be such a tremendous and
gracious move you'd have no choice but
to be like oh okay all right you know
that's the most outlandish alternate
universe i've ever heard of you you
think the democrats would be angry
absolutely they're bloodthirsty they
want everybody in jail they want
everybody that went to washington on
january 6 in jail forever i i i agree
but my point is that when faced with
having to admit that their guy betrayed
what they truly wanted they're more
about virtue signaling they wouldn't
throw a bite under the bus biden
is implementing policy that's damaging
to our energy sector and they claim the
opposite they it's like biden
literally
is enacting policy that causes gas
prices to go up and they come out and
they say biden can't control gas prices
then when it comes down they're like
biden did that
there's no moral consistency whatever
biden does is good and they were right
and just so that's why uh you know look
and look i'm not i'm not i'm not trying
to argue that it's absolutely true i'm
just trying to get your thoughts on it
because you know one of the things that
we're bringing up is how do we
de-escalate tensions is that one of the
ways we do it right biden coming out
just being like
the only way to simmer things down is to
is to pardon these guys well he's never
going to do that but yeah i agree with
you that if he did that might work but i
i don't see that i don't see anything
like that happening sometimes i think if
he were to do that it's the only way the
democrats would admit that he is like in
early stages of dementia or maybe not
early stages because then they would be
like see he's really not in a position
to be doing this like
i think you're right it would be
extremely difficult for a huge section
of the democratic party to justify this
to themselves i think tim's right there
would be some who would be like well
because of this
illogical
twisting of argument then this is why it
makes sense to do that but i do think
that there would be enough who would say
you know no he should only be pardoning
you know african-american men who have
done this like to pardon a majority
white crowd that went to this you know
like it would be
it would be really against narrative and
upstream and that's where i think they
would be like well i mean like if he had
done it his first day in office
maybe because they had enough they know
he's gonna be in office for a little
while but yeah he's halfway through
almost halfway through at this point we
can all kind of tell things are not
right we do not expect him to run again
if he were to uh pardon all of jr6
prisoners which of course i wish he
would uh
he would probably just get well it's
time for biden to retire we we didn't
really want him here anyways and how do
you get from the worst attack on our
nation's democracy since the civil war
to i'm just going to pardon it it's
covet you i mean we got to acknowledge
the covet caused massive strain and
stress on people's psychology it's not
just shutting down what happened as a
result of covid in the response to covet
but the covet virus when i had it i was
angry man and i was stressed out and tim
and me got into it one day we were
yelling like it it it causes people to
feel like crap and to get madness so
many people went nuts over the last two
and a half years like
pardon all those people that were
smashing up buildings in the summer of
2020 pardon them pardon hillary clinton
pardoned james clapper for lying under
oath pardoned the prison people that are
sitting
solitary we need to we need to scrub
clean the last 200 years of insanity
that we've declared on ourselves the
slave holders pardon them all man pardon
all the runaway slaves pardon them all
and like wendy's
would you keep pardoning people after
that though like i i understand the
instinct to want to be like let's just
start over but i think that like the
memories of everything that happened
runs too deep you wouldn't actually give
people a sense of justice or
satisfaction it would just be like we're
making the score zero except we all
secretly know it's not zero i don't
think abe lincoln thought he was doing
like what was politically correct when
he freed the slaves he just knew it had
to happen
anything to keep the union together he
wouldn't have pardoned the slaves if he
could have kept the union together he
did not it wasn't about morality for him
it was about preserving the sovereignty
of the nation and the economy and it was
also about destabilizing the south
because the emancipation proclamation
was
basically saying to all of the slaves
which were in southern states because
the north states were free
rise up against
the the the government there it was it
was weaponization of if anything i mean
i mean look abraham lincoln got in
the civil war had technically already
begun bleeding kansas was going on
several states had already seceded and
so he waited several years to actually
the free the slaves things wasn't a
civil war it was like the civil war was
going to happen anyway and then he
sought as an opportunity to do what he
thought was right i think you're wrong
and he took a bullet for it i mean
what it wasn't it wasn't like free the
slaves and then the civil war started it
was like years later that they decided
to freeze it wasn't it so abraham
lincoln your argument is that he maybe
wanted more troops and they wanted
southern slaves to fight on the side of
the world it was by destabilization yeah
it's partly about destabilization it
might have been i mean abraham lincoln
was a deeply racist individual like re
read the history of abraham lincoln read
about liberia and and like the letters
that abraham lincoln wrote
but it shouldn't be surprising anybody
i'm not trying to impugn the honor of
abraham lincoln i'm just pointing out
back then like literally everybody was
racist and so people people like to look
back and base past history and morality
on modern sensibilities which is just
not correct yeah right abraham lincoln
was and was didn't what did not want to
be the president
during the collapse of the united states
and so it was very political i mean the
dude suspended habeas corpus up through
a corridor from dc through maryland to
pennsylvania where they were just
arresting people without charge and
holding them indefinitely this is not a
guy who believes in freedom and doing
right it's a guy about who who believed
in winning by any means necessary i
think the slavery thing was like a moral
thing for him no he said if i could have
kept the union together without freeing
slaves i would have done it i mean he
was completely dedicated to keeping the
union as a nation i think we're taught
that in school that it is about slavery
and it's about morality because our
sensibilities have changed and i think
if you were president now
in that time you would have behaved
differently but for labraham lincoln it
wasn't about slavery and i think
we're just told to turn a blind eye to
that it was about preserving the union
the economics yeah he wanted the money
from the south
i think it's complicated i mean i
there's a really great letter ulysses
says grant wrote where he said that the
union sacrificed blood and treasure to
admit these states into the union and
they swore an oath
by seceding they were in violation of
their oath and effectively stealing that
blood and treasure for you know for
themselves and so he he wrote that um
anyone any man has a right to rebel
against his
against his government or leaders or
authority or whatever just know that if
you lose you will have to live under
their you know
command and penalty you know from that
point forward so it's interesting
actually reading what these guys wrote
about what was going on back then it's
it's it's truly crazy stuff thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you